Ok i thought. It's not. So they're not they're not.
So we're trying to you know you know this country has to be so good. Well. I came to the seri about fourteen years ago.
My name's katrina shields. And i came to this area. Fourteen years ago. Originally to live on a community called buddy.
That had about twenty adults and fifteen children. That time. And i had been living in another community. In victoria.
That i'd joined. To coming back from india. Had lived in the case.
And particularly india or new poll for a couple of these and.
I knew i didn't want to go back to being an occupational therapist and. Working as a professional. In the mind stream.
So i guess i chose to drop. Brought out. But i was very much attracted to what was happening in this area. And.
On hearing about body found i came up here and. Originally to do a month long meditation retreat.
And i stayed and joined body firm and lived there for four and a half years and still part of that community. And.
But have since moved to the village nearby. And come and go on that. What you originally. I was drawn to the ethical.
Structure that. The. I was strongly influenced and interested in buddhist meditation practice and.
Had been involved in that very strongly in india and i knew i wanted to live a rural community life. But the community.
I was on had a very loose. Structure and wasn't really working for me. And when i met.
These people i guess i was really struck by the spirit. You know there was something that they had going as a group.
That particularly the men. The way they were together that. They're really soft and are open and sharing.
That was the initial thing that attracted me. And then they told me about the structure of the community.
And the fact that the thought buddhist precepts were the bice's of the community. And that just instantly.
Struck a chord with me. And i wanted to go and find out.
And as soon as i walked in i just had this really strong feeling this is my place. You know. And it.
And i just fell into place it is. And i was very happy being there no still feel very strongly connected to that group.
And feel like they my key in law i have a large extended family. In melbourne. These people.
The would say was to cover. How i feel. You know we don't always like each other but.
But there's a strong commitment to each other and we know. Tapes about it tether and. Yeah. We just you know us.
So the sticking together was. Yeah it was very much motivation. And surely by nina search. Him.
Initially i was motivated by and. In a sort of spiritual inquiry and. Personal growth. That's what initially drew me.
Of wanting to discover more about myself.
Had to grow as a person had to overcome my own hang ups had to explain myself and.
So i was very attracted to old thoughts of personal growth. Stuff and also learning had a buddha and.
Grow vegetables and. Mud bricks and.
You know live very simply because i've been i've lived in india and saw how they lived there
and it really touched me very deeply that i just couldn't go on consuming and. Having as much as i saw.
Around me i see that we couldn't sustain that. So i was very attracted to living very simply and.
Then it sort of grew from there that i asked or a number of years i felt drawn back into the mind string.
That i wanted to to make bridges. Back into water a society that somehow.
Wasn't i wasn't personally being naresh to nothing about the oscillation. Of the community.
But also i wanted to be stretched. I actually stepped up by sitting as.
Sitting up a small business in lismore health food business. But then i was also also a lark i'm spec.
Doing occupational therapy and health promotion which is what i've done before. So that drew me back.
So i wanted to span the two worlds.
And to say ok we've experimented with where the alternatives would and learnt a lot in the process hack
and we use that to sort of naresh what was happening in the mind stream. You know and bring.
Really good things about the mind stream. Back into the alternative. Society.
Hell it was things about time management and being efficient and getting things done and really making things happen.
Then i wanted to also bring back into old end of society with it that it wasn't all about. You know.
Just lies in rent having a good. Ah. Actually we worked really hard.
It's not true that we sat around on the trees contemplating and ovals i think.
I think i probably worked had in those days. You know a six day now a days.
It was making mud bricks or working in the god. So sometimes we're actually workaholic about. We did that.
We had a good time. Yes quite strict. Yeah. And i was probably amongst the. The stricter.
You know i was really on about being audie logically sound and. You know everybody should work really haddad and.
You couldn't have anything but organic vegetables and.
You know alcohol was very to brew and cigarettes were out right just and. You know our calves were morally unsound.
I was pretty strict
and i guess a lot of us were we were very idealistic you know we really wanted to be sound about what we were doing
and we didn't want to be on the dull. Saw that meant. Living on the smell of an oily rag.
And getting by very little because we didn't have many sources of income.
So yeah i think we're pretty hard line of softened up a lot. You know. I don't think it was bad.
To be like that but i don't know if that was so sustainable. So.
I moved back into the mainstream and now working part time as a counselor in a women's health center.
Focusing particularly on older women. But i also do training and development work with community groups.
Run workshops and trainings and take. Conflict resolution.
Working together and have been at strategies and team building things like that. You know. Yeah yeah.
Well look i grew out of it. I think. I ended up writing a book which was a synthesis all the ideas.
And the experiments we've had and learning from each other and living in community.
In vain both in social change campaigns fighting for the rainforests working on pace issues. And also.
Synthesizing the. Personal growth. The counseling the creativity and.
Learning how to be effective in social change work. And bringing in more hot. Politics approach into what we do.
So this. This turned into a menu. Of all those different aspects. With exercises that.
I and others had used to grow and to work together in groups though.
Ok well the term hot politics was originally coined by a woman called. Friend pavey. Who happened to be american and.
Yes it means bringing together that. Which is normally sane is a separate.
But the how they are most vulnerable path to a loving caring. And you know most being. Bringing that together with.
Influencing social change having power. The structures that. Bring about. Movement in society and.
We often see how that is being incredibly separate from that that. A lot of the models of power of social change.
Saying is you know you. Corrupt. Just that he's so. Wielding power and not caring about the consequences.
That any means justify the means and all of us feel pretty disgusted by that and. Very unattractive.
To that way of bringing about change.
So we've been experimenting with a whole lot of different bias to bring the two together what.
What does the personal growth. And spiritual movement have to do with nourishing political and.
And sustaining political action. And drawing people in who feel powerless and and involved.
We originally got attracted to this. During the early eighty's when.
Many of us felt incredible despair about the nuclear issue that we had a piece of information about what was.
Lockley to happen what could happen what was happening and. It was pretty had to respond. The threat was so huge and.
You know i felt sickened. An overwhelmed and depressed and.
We came across some methods for transforming those feelings. Into effective action.
And that was to actually grief to validate it to spay
and to recognize that our responses were really a sign reaction to an in science situation.
And that perhaps no other generation of the sysop. Squarely. To the fact of its own extinction. That.
Many of us grew up feeling like. They just wasn't a future where there is an alternative future.
Or whether it was the one mapped out to it by the mainstream. So that's a pretty had thing. To give up.
The feeling like what's the use of having children. You know if we do have children what are we bringing them into.
So we're facing. Pretty strong despair. And so we experimented with methods. Working with grief. Ritual work.
Support groups.
To bring that out and what we found was that by going quite deeply into that despair that
and hopelessness that we felt that actually liberated. A lot of energy and hope that was the amazing thing that.
The more we had knowledge to fully. The mohel passion for life. Came through. And then actually.
We were connecting deeper sources of energy. And realizing that that. Pain came from.
I have a feeling an unknowing a very into connectedness. We hurt. Because we cade. We hurt.
Because we were part of life and life was threatened. We weren't personally necessarily threatened.
But we could see what was happening to other species and. What might happen.
And so it was by validating then interconnection that. The more power. And sense of being able to effect change grew.
But then we also needed to learn skills. You know.
How do you organize how do you run groups how do you conduct meetings how do you get release that really get people
along. Heck and we have fun doing this. We're going to be doing it the rest of our life you know.
So we really want to enjoy it. And so a lot of. What we've learnt in. Living in community. And working on social.
Campaigns you know brought back together with this emotional and spiritual work. You know. Well yeah yeah. That. Ok.
So we're trying to make something positive out of something that was very negative. Like a threat to the future.
The possible loss. Completely of a future. Or at least.
All this beauty and this environment that we could see around us. The extinction of species.
Pollution of the air and water. Had to turn that into a source. But also celebration.
And drawing on inner resources in a selves and in it and see that.
Yes as a cause for celebration that you have this much to do. And that can be done joyfully and. Hopefully effectively.
Because it's not just about having a good time we also want to make effective change. And that's.
That's an ongoing challenge to me but a lot of these people that are very.
Left brain and like we've got no time for fun and. You know.
We've got no time to sit down and work on our relationships.
Because the campaign you know there's this campaign and there's this mating and. Hell is this deadline. Like.
That's that's no more effective. You know so really facing up to the fact that if you burn people out.
And you have such a lousy time. It doesn't work. You know if it's. You know building a social change movement.
So the same that. Building movements.
The change really needed something much more integrated that we knew had lived together
when you had a result of conflicts. When you had to support each other we knew had. Effectively matings.
You know stick to agendas plan. Campaigns and. A lot of the lessons of community came at that.
That if you can live together in bringing a few children together and solve your conflicts. You've got great resources.
Then going out and changing what's happening in newtown or changing what's happening. Why did the newtown.
Well perhaps.
The how politics visit with it was similar i to actually see it as an integration off of mescaline
and the feminine principles. If you lock. If you say traditionally the feminine principle is being about. You know.
Caring and had to nurturing and nurturing and the masculine principle about being.
You know organized in effect to the up front and. Leadership. And exercising power.
I see the hap politics as bringing those two together. They're both necessary. All hat.
You know much feel good but it's not going to bring about change necessarily and ole old head isn't going to last
and people won't want to be part of it. So.
I see how politics is bringing the hate in the you know the spirit in the body. The mescaline and timonen. Together.
And to now. And hopefully have the best of both. Yeah.
That's what you want to give them they're what makes it extremely wise.
So what some of the extremes we went to in the early days.
Well there was extreme hardline and i know i was one of those.
Really trying to stick very rigidly to audiology and to anything from the mind strain that might be you know.
I have alternatives. But i guess we're pretty extreme about. You know with things like..
Experimenting with bio energy to their p. You know. Because we're laces and. And you know nudity and.
Things like rats and. You know i look back and chuckle. Now at some of those things some of the. The the no i even.
Perhaps that we approach. Things. And i was thinking about. You know i saw a set up a small business and.
Selling health foods. And i was incredibly naive about business.
I went in thinking i was just doing it because it was doing good it never occurred to me that would make money
or that it should make money. You know i just didn't think like that. It was just. What's good for the group.
Now i think i'd stop and say well. Is this going to make it because that matters.
So i don't know what other extremes pepsi extremes of sort of polity. That were subjected us. To mean.
I lived for quite a long time in a taint. In the rainforest. And then. You waited on to shades. Without walls.
Amongst the leeches and the ticks and the snakes and the frogs and. I mean that had its real beauty.
But it wasn't that practical and you clouds went moldy and. You know you got sick and.
Got pretty called and damp and wear it and. I don't think you could keep that up and.
You know washing your claws in the crate with cold water and. You know.
Didn't have any electricity because that was very bush. So yeah. It was really good to experience that.
But it wasn't sustainable. You know. I guess i got sick of that and.
I discovered when i wanted to move back into the mainstream and. Hold down a job. Even if it was a pat down job. Well.
I had to turn up looking kind of reasonable. But i wasn't any good if my clothes were covered in mold and. You know.
Hadn't been washed and. Even though i might have really good reasons for that.
It just wasn't going to go out and very well. Yeah. It wasn't deliberate. Yeah. It wasn't deliberate to say you know.
Ok poll we are or whatever. But. But yeah. Aspas who were trying to stretch the limits of house.
And how self-sufficient also. Really strongly about being self-sufficient. That it mattered. That a groom on food.
And if that meant that i was only living on. You know. The vegetables that are they got and then that's what i do.
And i used to feel offended if people went and bought imported. Tofu. Something like that. You know if it offended.
Some really strongly held principle and. You know you could make your own clothes and could recycle and.
You know you could cut down use of the cab and. We didn't need electricity and water was a bit of a luxury and.
Yeah i think i took it a bit. Ronit. Well the book's cold in the target man.
And that grew out of the four time we were joined on the community by.
I put this monk who was a political refugee from thailand. His loss was threatened by his political activities and.
So he lived on the farm and wrote poetry and paintings and. Contemplated and. He gave the painting to each person.
On the community and i came home one day and on the floor of my hat. He'd done this painting.
In very simple brush strokes all. A rampant. Tyga. And the caption was the best place for meditation.
Is in the target man and.
I couldn't make a lot of sense of it at the time but i realized later that then i was very much into withdrawal.
That i wanted to practice meditation and. Be away from the hurly burly. To be quiet and to be with my. My clan.
With my chosen family and perhaps not have to mix it with that. Rather yucky world at the and.
Lighter and when we came involved in campaigns to size the rainforest
and other social issues are realize what he was getting at he was saying hey maybe. Meditation really has.
Through ition. When you can keep an open mind and open hat in the spirit of inquiry. When you're in the thick of it.
You know. And get back out there. So that's been my challenge and. I think that he was. What i was trying to tell me.
Yeah yeah. You know. And surely. I think.
My focus was on my personal growth the now groups personal growth and creating alternative. And now.
I see the movement back into the mainstream. To take. What we've learned. And experimented with. Back in and take.
What's good about it. And then straight back into the alternative that they're not so separate now.
I mean things we were talking about that were considered extremely radical i mean organic a culture.
Or even you know sharing in community or. Things like that. And now just.
Very run of the mill it everybody can talk about it. Which is great. Oh hades. Well the world's.
Still in a pretty bad state and. There's just. I mean it's a worse state than it was fourteen years ago.
Maybe the uniquely clad has lifted. Some water. Although we have still have an enormous threat from nuclear waste.
That it hasn't gone away. So there's lots of challenges. About how we're really going to affect change.
And what to do that we're going to have to work together in wise. Which were than he had glimpses of and.
I think one of the pres the. Legacies of the post aquarius. Was.
You know how can we can't come together and live
and learn from each other in a in a very open way that that lesson still needs to go on.
You know we need to not have have can we actually sustain life on earth. And cooperate and understand each other it's.
I mean it's happening all over the world it's not just the seri are of course. But we need it more than. You ran.
Initially most spiritual. Was focused very much on. Meditation practice. I saw that as being the main vehicle for.
Growth and change. And most. Most sitting practice. To get in contact with.
Deep energies within myself and to understand. My mind and. It's hard to talk. And living as a strong ethical.
Structure of the buddha's precepts. Was important. Now. Us.
Say that is still important i don't meditate as much as i used to us do. Like to have a retreat.
Once see what we can be in silence and get back in contact with myself.
But i try and bring my spiritual practice into everything i do. You know whether it's doing the counseling work.
I do with women oh. Working on a campaign to clean up. You know the local area or.
Working on a committee in the local government. To introduce small community consultation. I say that. As the arraign s.
A spiritual practice hack and i listen to this person that i have incredibly different views.
With and still stay open hatted and. How can i find a way to cooperate.
You know how can i work on my own stuff so that we're not so much in conflict.
Heck going on one time will balance and hack and i keep trusting. You know just trusting that. That is good.
In other people that there's good around me. And that i can draw an energy. That's much bigger and wider than me.
I mean this times. When i'm running workshops and maybe.
I'm facilitating a conflict it happened last week a large group. Thirty three people. Lots of conflict.
And they've brought me into try and you know.
Fix it up and i'm still standing there thinking hell i can't do this you know.
This is too had i'd rather be anywhere that he had this just feel terrible.
But maybe it's just that moment of thinking well. I'm not just me. You know maybe i can i've been myself.
Too wide energies. You know i cannot be a channel here. For having these people appreciate each other you know.
To get back to buy six and. Find some some caring and. Willing to listen. And.
So maybe it's just a moment of reflection and grounding and praying. Really and and when i do that.
Amazing things happen. You know.
And i know that's not just coming from me so i guess that's how some of the ways in which i experience.
Spiritual practice now. Yeah. Are remind optimistic by saying results. Yeah. I actually say that this stuff works.
That people can cooperate. That.
I have experience growth in myself i've experienced enormous growth in the people around me.
I've seen groups turn around from a point of conflict and hug closeness to. Optimism and cooperation.
I've seen campaigns that work. I've seen have said the change in consciousness about rainforests. You know.
In in ten years. It's really turned around. Saw all remain optimistic. By saying the results and.
By having a good time. As ago. That i enjoy what i do. And that. That feeds me and. I work with a lot of loving people.
And that saves me yeah. Yeah i think i am. I think this is the korean ideals i see. Very relevant.
I mean they not know about long hair isn't beads and. You know when pregnant. I mean that externals.
But i say the values of cooperation of living closely to the earth. To being open to night. Voluntary simplicity.
Experimentation. Personal growth. I see them as incredibly relevant.
More relevant now than they were then you know that. Perhaps there was no evil idealism and.
Perhaps it would force the wood. It's self absorption. But that we're good ideals and see the ninety's as being.
You know the place where they hated more than ever. You know they.
The excesses of the eighty's and the greed of the eighty's.
Has really taught us that we need it more than ever
when i say women's issue is being a strong thread that's been running through the growth will change.
I mean for me as a woman but also in the movements. Our member we've made a video of. The struggle for to rainy.
Creek rainforest a bat. Thirteen years ago. And in playing it again. I remember people saying.
Yeah but where are the women. You know. The guys who are getting up and talking. That we're really taking the lead.
We were certainly there. We were doing a lot of work. But we weren't speaking up and. We didn't see that as our place.
You know. So in fact.
There was a hell of a lot of sure going isn't really running through a lot of the alternative communities.
The women were barefoot and pregnant washing the. Well the guys were happy wearing and.
In fact six were also very strong. And i. They were very strong in a lot of social change groups.
So it's been really important for women to get together and to in paris so. And to draw on the water women's movement.
To nourish action within the alternative community and. You know peace groups and in community action groups.
To say hey we've got we've got an equivalent. We've got skills. We need to be empowered.
We need to empower each other and. Work together is a cools.
And so that's been that's been an important lesson i think that came quite light. To the alternative movement.
Well things that were acceptable still on communities around here. Wouldn't have been acceptable in that.
In many of the city groups. There was also a difference as well. Yes yes i think the. The shia. Physical reality.
That many of us were living in. Unfortunately. Initially halasz at some of the six rolls. Is a baby on the way.
And this has to be built. You know is this a time for the woman. You know stab at square one learning how to build.
Oh she's got a baby on the hip. I mean who. You know.
Is it going to be quicker for her to wash the nappies and feed the baby and him to get on with building.
And unfortunately. You know. Efficiency. Route. Often and. And it. And it got more and more ingrained in that way.
But many of us said why.